previously nominated for an Oscar for
his performance in 12 monkeys
please welcome Brad Pitt
three things he learned wouldn't start
acting in films show up on time know
your lines and kiss up to the
cinematographer in the category Best
Cinematography here are the nominees
Conrad L Hall for American Beauty
Roger Pratt for the end of the affair
Dante's finale for the inside
Emmanuel Lubezki sleepy huh
Robert Richardson our snow falling on
Cedars
and the Oscar goes to
Conrad L Hall
this is the second Academy Award for
Conrad L Hall and his
won an Oscar in this category in 1969
for Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
Oh
oh my god feels like family night with
the Burnham's and the Spitz's I'm
looking at somebody that I gotta say
thanks to immediately because he
happened to mention my name to a guy
named Sam Mendes and guess what huh this
happened I can't tell you what a great
experience it has been working with this
team from DreamWorks the producers Dan
and and senior moments Bruce from a
script that I didn't know how we were
going to get a movie that anybody liked
because they were such unusual
characters and until like Sam pointed
out to me uh don't you ever have any
unusual thoughts yourself Conrad about
the 16 year old girls and let your duck
they can accompany your daughter home
and I thought oh well so I guess
I guess we're all part of a wonderful
wonderful dysfunctional family called
the human race uh and Fitz's and the
Burnham's and everybody else is partakes
of it but my best family is here tonight
huh they're my children my grandchildren
and whose love have like supported me
all these years and and and I know I'm
gonna forget something and I don't know
what it is but it's up the team that I
had working with with me the Aaron peas
and Ian Clyde Brian and Susan trucks and
my son Conrad who shot some Conrad w
shot some additional scenes for us and
David ghoulia what a great time was
working Sam you are the best huh when
you showed up looking exactly like Orson
Welles I thought to myself oh my god you
know and now I know he's like Orson
Welles anyway thank you to the Academy
itself
you